[Musica]
sera pensavo di veder di più ma invece
non vedo nulla quindi ecco vediamo se
riesco a vedere i vostri volti perché
quando Andrea pauri mi ha invitato qui a
far lo speech davanti a voi al Ted
parlando di lusso Beh Andrea In realtà
io non devo dire nulla il lusso Per me è
questo il lusso bellezza l'armonia è
questo essere qui questa sera di fronte
a
voi devo dirvi che da un po' di mesi a
questa
parte ho pensato a come poter iniziare
questo speech ho detto colpi di scena
citazioni Come posso sciogliere il
ghiaccio parlando di Loo un Ted e quindi
inizierò con una curiosità abbastanza
bizzarra perché secondo me qualcun altro
di voi può condividere con me non dico
proprio questa passione ma qualcosa di
simile dovete sapere infatti che quando
io sono sotto stress O provo ansia mi
rifugio in quelli che sono documentari o
letture
sull'universo lo
spazio-tempo l'universo che si espande i
buchi neri che con il lusso non
c'entrano nulla e non c'entrano nulla
nemmeno con quello che so con quello che
ho studiato sono profondamente ignorante
Eppure è come se pensare all'enormità
del l'universo mi facesse rilassare
della serie Marina tranquilla Ci sono
cose più importanti più gravi prima o
poi passa tutto Maa che abbiamo sciolto
un attimino il ghiaccio e ci siamo
conosciuti di più voglio parlare di
qualcosa che forse abbiamo in
comune Quanti di voi per esempio
Alzatevi le manine Anche se le vedo male
Hanno almeno una volta nella vita letto
un libro ho fatto un corso su qualcosa o
qualcuno che ci prometteva di esser
bravi Capaci ad influenzare l'altro i
corsi Avete presente come conquistare
una donna in una settimana un uomo in
due giorni Come convincere il tuo capo
che sei più bravo di lui in una
settimana Quanti di voi hanno fatto
almeno una volta nella vita Un corso una
lettura del genere Io sono la prima sono
la prima che nella mia vita ho iniziato
giovane a 14 anni la la camminata sui
braccieri ardenti tanto ce la fa e tanto
va Tutto bene
il concetto di influenzare la capacità
di coinvolgere l'altro mi ha fatto un
po'
riflettere sul fatto che il lusso di per
sé è proprio il mondo per eccellenza
della
coinvolgimento la capacità di
influenzarci ma Pensateci ora Quanto è
bello entrare all'interno di una
boutique
in un bel negozio in uno shom d'auto
dipende da quello che vi piace ed essere
accolti
coccolati luci
perfette sembra un Cosmo diverso Un
universo parallelo di solito tendiamo al
disordine invece all'interno di una
boutique sembra tutto seduttivo veniamo
Coccolati e questo è bellissimo ci fa
creare quasi un desiderio di posseder
tutto volete comprarlo siete disposti a
investire anche di più rispetto a quello
che potrebbe essere un prodotto quasi
medesimo ma non all'interno di quella
struttura e quindi partiamo dal
presupposto che il lusso riesce ad
influenzarci ma mi svelo un altro
piccolo aneddoto Dato che dobbiamo
conoscerci io ho studiato lusso e ci
lavoro anche ma vi dirò la
verità probabilmente io non ho iniziato
perché sul serio mi interessava il lusso
io iniziato perché faceva bello dirlo
all'esterno Era bello quando qualcuno mi
chiedeva cos'è che studia l'action in
Management in che settore lavori lusso è
come se tutta la forza di un settore del
genere così luccicante così bello mi si
vestisse addosso cioè io mi sentivo
forte eppure Credetemi ero l'ultima
ruota del carro io di lusso non ne
sapevo assolutamente nulla ma faceva
figo dirlo e molti di voi probabilmente
fanno delle cose compiono delle
azioni solo perché è bello dirlo è bello
mostrarlo A questo punto la
domanda che più mi viene posta e che io
faccio agli altri è sempre la stessa
cos'è per voi effettivamente il
lusso se nel vostro immaginario ci sono
quelle che sono vetture Gio Elli abiti
costosi viaggi attici case bellissime
sicuramente il lusso è anche questo è
una parte è corretto però qualcuno prima
di me come Abraham Maslow nel
1954 feci quella che è considerata una
piramide la piramide dei bisogni quindi
stiamo parlando di cinque tipologie di
bisogni e tra la necessità umana di
respirare dormire
mangiare nei primi tre ma soprattutto
all'apice troviamo l'autorealizzazione
il senso di gratificazione di
appartenenza sociale e quindi cosa
significa che il lusso Forse non è tanto
superficiale lusso effettivamente non è
solo acquistare un prodotto il lusso
Forse è anche un bisogno Un bisogno di
sentirsi a volte qualcun altro un lusso
è qualcosa che ci dà sicurezza ci dà
potere
Eppure qualcun altro diceva che il lusso
non è altro che qualcosa di
costoso difficile da trovare non è un
bisogno ma un desiderio ed
effettivamente Qual è la differenza tra
bisogno e desiderio Se voi ci fate caso
ogni volta che voi andate ad acquistare
o a raggiungere quello che era un vostro
grande obiettivo un vostro bisogno
voi subito dopo cosa succede avete
finito No provvedete un altro desiderio
e quindi ci sarà la nascita di un nuovo
bisogno soddisfatto quello ci sarà un
altro desiderio e noi saremo sempre
coinvolti all'interno di un circolo che
continua continua All'infinito E sapete
però tornando al termine di lusso alla
nostra borsetta cosa succede che la
prima volta che l'avete vista
la desideravate tantissimo la volevate
poi siete riuscita ad acquistare il
prodotto il bene il servizio che tanto
ambiva come se fosse una promessa di
felicità una volta
posseduta bello sfoggiamo sentiamo la
sua energia la sua luce dopo un po' di
giorni Un po' di tempo la luce che
emanava all'inizio inizia a svanire ed è
così che
ciò che inizialmente
ambivo così tanto e ci dava forza a
distanza di tempo diventa banale
monotona
obsoleta questo qui che c'entra con il
lusso centra il fatto
che qui Voglio fare una riflessione con
voi non tanto sul termine non tanto su
cos'è cosa non è perché secondo me il
lusso fondamentalmente non esiste
percezione
ma oggi a distanza di
anni ho capito che il lusso Per me è
consapevolezza Qualcuno di voi ha mai
associato questo termine a
consapevolezza ma la consapevolezza di
cosa la consapevolezza significa sapere
effettivamente il valore di
qualcosa qualcosa o qualcuno che noi
abbiamo è il nostro più grande lusso
pensate ora se Poe tornare indietro nel
tempo Quanti di voi considererebbero
lusso poter avere un abbraccio una
carezza da qualcuno un vostro parente Un
amore una persona a voi cara quanto
Vorreste tornare indietro e quanto
magari in passato non vi rendevo nemmeno
di avere questo lusso a portata di
mano quante cose noi facciamo nella
quotidianità
nella quale poi ci stanchiamo perché
semplicemente diventano monotone ci
hanno
stancato le persone che sono accanto a
noi non ci rendiamo più conto ma non ci
rendiamo nemmeno conto di quello che noi
quotidianamente facciamo perché la vita
va veloce perché a volte non è
abbastanza bello pubblicare la nostra
normalità sui social no quante volte
capita io in primis sono un caso Cioè in
primis so benissimo che pubblico sui
social ci lavoro quella che è la mia
parte di vita una parte la parte bella
la parte scintillante la parte luminosa
che gli altri si aspettano di vedere da
me ok ma che ne sapete che io il 90%
delle volte non consideri lusso la il
potere di tornare a casa di stare con la
mia famiglia e semplicemente riposare
però non lo pubblico Non lo pubblico
perché non è abbastanza figo non è
abbastanza quello che si aspettano le
persone quindi la mia riflessione di
oggi è con voi come
possiamo
quotidianamente esser noi gli autori del
nostro lusso Come possiamo rendere la
nostra vita da banale a monotona a
qualcosa di
straordinario e se non c'è
consapevolezza di chi siamo di chi
vogliamo di di tutto quello che abbiamo
intorno dalle cose più semplici a quelle
più complesse sarà difficile gustare il
vero lusso perché non lo troverete
all'esterno Credetemi non sarà una casa
in piazza d'omo a rendervi più fighi più
lussuosi non sarà questo non sarà avere
l'orologio non sarà avere la macchina
sicuramente uno status bene ci piace ma
non è
questo il mio spunto di oggi sul serio è
quello di farvi riflettere riflettere
con me perché in primis non mi sono mai
fermata nella mia vita e sono l'opposto
di quello che è lusso vengo da una
famiglia molto umile che di lusso non
aveva assolutamente nulla Oggi ho la
fortuna di lavorare con Brand
internazionali di essere qui con voi a
parlare di una cosa tanto lontano da me
e sapete cosa ho capito Alla fine di
tutto questo lavoro alla fine del dover
lavorare lavorare lavorare portare i
risultati mostrarsi agli altri che io il
lusso me lo creo da sola e io me lo creo
da sola tutti i giorni con le persone
che ho intorno con le persone che scelgo
come scelgo di vivere la mia vita con il
sorriso con la
gratificazione il mio invito quindi è
questo Come l'inizio non avevo una frase
o una citazione importante da fare non
avete visto slide e non ho nemmeno una
frase di chiusura Mi auguro solo che da
questo da questi pochi minuti voi
possiate fermarvi un attimo e iniziare a
capire cos'è veramente il lusso per
voi come potete rendere la vostra vita
da normale a
straordinaria essere grati essere fieri
di quello che siete di quello che potete
fare e ambire solo a quello che
veramente vi rende felici perché l'unico
lusso
l'unico siete voi e lo create voi non
c'è nessun altro nessun oggetto che
potrà darvi questa
sensazione buona
serata